LILA BARTON
This is the first Christmas
we've had together
in years.
CLINT BARTON
I love you guys.
I'm making up
for some lost time.
NEWSCASTER
Authorities are wondering if the
masked vigilante, who terrorized
the city's underworld, is back.
CLINT BARTON
The past has caught up with me.
LILA BARTON
Should we be worried?
CLINT BARTON
No, no, it's nothing.
I'll be home for Christmas,
I promise.
♪♪
♫ It's the most wonderful time ♫
CLINT BARTON
When I wore this suit,
I made a
whole lot of enemies.
KATE BISHOP
You're Hawkeye!
CLINT BARTON
Who the hell are you?
KATE BISHOP
Some people have actually called me...
[Bell ringing]
...the world's
greatest archer.
CLINT BARTON
Are you one of those people?
♫ It's the most wonderful time ♫
CLINT BARTON
Hey babe, I should be back
in...
a day or two?
Hang on a second.
♫ With the kids jingle belling
And everyone telling you ♫
CLINT BARTON
Things have gotten...
[Rope snaps]
[Screaming]
...more complicated.
CLINT BARTON
[Sighs]
♫ The most wonderful time
Of the year ♫
KATE BISHOP
[Grunts]
CLINT BARTON
[Sighs]
♪♪
♫ It's the most wonderful time
Yes, the most wonderful time ♫
CLINT BARTON
This is too dangerous.
Definitely not this one.
KATE BISHOP
You don't have to say "definitely"
like that.
Holy...
There are arrows
more dangerous than that one?
♫ Of the year ♫
CLINT BARTON
Ugh, this is some Christmas.